hey everyone Devonte Chisholm here with
Jake Decker who got the chance to get
Hands-On with The Witcher 3 complete
edition on PlayStation 5 and Xbox series
X Jake how was it well first of all I
love The Witcher uh and this complete
edition seems to deliver it looks
stunning it's hard to believe that this
game is seven years old and it still
looks this good obviously CD projekt Red
has done a ton to lift it up a little uh
improve some of the rougher edges but
for the most part it looks
like had I not played The Witcher so
recently I'd say it looks like I
remember it but if you really sit there
and compare the two uh it it seems like
a very impressive
upgrade that is technically free I mean
you still need to own the game but uh if
you already own it it just it's gonna
get patched right in yeah which is so
exciting and and you're right it
like for me even opening the game
earlier today it's like I look at it and
I'm like you look so good how can you
possibly look better but right gear over
here telling me it can so I'm that's
that's very exciting it it feels like it
holds its own with current gen
PlayStation 5 Xbox series X Games I will
say the the combat feels very much of
its time and that's not necessarily a
bad thing but it sounds bad to say but
it doesn't feel as Dark Souls inspired
as many modern third-person action games
do okay but that's not necessarily a bad
thing but visually it looks it looks it
looks amazing can you talk about the
like the two modes since you were
playing on Console
um I know that there's your typical
performance and quality mode did you get
a chance to play with both of them yeah
I bounced between the two quite a bit on
both PlayStation 5 and Xbox series X so
there is a performance mode which high
frame rates I I think it's targeting 60
on just about everything although it
supports variable
um refresh rate TVs so if you have one
of those TVs it looks even smoother and
then there's also a ray tracing mode now
the raytrace lighting is sub model uh so
I'd keep that in mind and it runs at a I
believe a 30 frames per second so it
doesn't run quite as smooth but the
lighting looks a little better
particularly uh when you look at
backgrounds when you look at how
lighting bounces off walls when you look
at torches it looks
a little more natural uh it's still I'd
still say it's it's pretty subtle I mean
some areas I really had to flip between
the two to notice the difference so for
me personally I think I would lean to
Performance mode just because the
lighting already looks really good I
kind of just want it to run
at its best yeah that's kind of what I
figured I was gonna do
um personally in pretty much every game
I always pick performance mode I just
you know I need those frames
um but like with the ray tracing stuff
you know we am I going to want to turn
that on for the Game's new photo mode
Yes actually I was gonna mention that so
that's when I would usually turn it on
when I was getting ready to take photos
I would switch to Ray tracing mode press
in both both the thumb sticks and then
it automatically goes to the the photo
mode now nice I will say the photo mode
isn't quite as robust as you've seen in
contemporary games that have photo modes
when I was talking to the folks at city
project right they were saying that
this game was not built for photo mode
so they kind of had to do some
they had to do some delicate Maneuvers
in order to get it working and
personally I don't really mind like some
things missing is you can't change
geralt's pose you can't change his
facial expression you can't change time
of day
um at least in the build I played I
didn't see that which is a bit of a
bummer but honestly I think the real
draw to photo mode is just that the game
looks absolutely stunning I mean I when
I was taking notes I would just go to
photo mode raise the camera up super
high over Vistas and just leave it there
listen to the music while I was taking
notes writing and then hop back in
unfortunately I couldn't take any of the
photos with me that I took but I imagine
people are going to take some incredible
photos because
like I said the game looks amazing the
way you're describing it right now is
just it feels like a studying with Geral
you know you're just putting on some
music yeah vibing out to the rest of the
game
um
but okay photo mode but there's also new
camera modes so talk to me a little bit
about the the new type of angles we can
get on Garrow yes so for exploration
combat and horseback there is an
alternate camera that you can turn on
you can even customize it too so you can
say you want the alternate camera for
combat and exploration but you want the
default camera for horseback riding and
as you switch between those different
actions the camera will adjust I mostly
played with the new camera angle believe
it or not I thought it was really cool
particularly for exploration and combat
because it pushes in quite a bit so it
feels more over the shouldery obviously
it's not that close but you feel much
closer to girl closer to the action
closer to the environments so for me
I I actually preferred that
um I think maybe horseback riding I
could see why someone wouldn't want to
use the closer camera just so you can
get a better view of your environment
yeah but I think if you've played The
Witcher
you know multiple times it might be
worth checking out those new camera
modes because especially for exploration
it is uh it it it's cool seeing the
world through that through that Vision
through that view I was thinking I would
kind of stay wide for the combat than
maybe getting close for exploration and
maybe wide again for but the fact that
you can just mix and match and
experiment with them seems awesome I
like the the level of you know
customization they're giving to such a
you know old game not to not to like
downplay the game or anything because
it's still fantastic what about the new
signs well not the new signs but you
know don't have to slow down time bring
up the radio menu anymore
um so how did that feel yeah so the way
it works I believe you hold R2
um or right trigger depending on what
you're playing on and then from there
all of the face buttons correspond to
different signs as well as I think L1 or
left bumper so basically mid combat you
can basically hold down right trigger
and then just press a face button and
you'll use that sign uh I it was a bit
weird to get used to for me I think it's
just because I have played so much of
the original and I'm so used to pulling
up that radio menu picking the sign and
and uh using it it's also weird because
I don't really know the signs by name or
necessarily I know them by symbol
because I'm so used to going to that
radio menu it's like oh purple edrin
that's how I'm gonna deal with specters
but I think once I get time with it and
get the hang of it I think that'll be a
much better way to use signs and and
even like make more of a dedicated magic
uh sign build now as if this game needed
any more content as if it needs any more
quests you got to play a new one can you
talk about that a little bit Yeah so
this was probably one of the biggest
surprises now I know they had already
announced that they were adding Netflix
inspired content and there would be a
new quest to it but I guess I just
wasn't ready to hear Doug cockle the
voice of geralt return and they brought
him back in to record new lines they
wrote out a quest and the quest is
actually pretty good I don't want to
spoil it because
it's more Witcher content and I feel
like the people who are going to check
that out are going to be very excited to
see what happens but it explores an area
that
is in the original game but it was kind
of underutilized so they add a little
bit of of lore to that area once again
I'm being vague because I don't want to
spoil it but they add a bit of lore and
then I think that my favorite thing
about it is that it gives context to a
lot of these new Netflix inspired items
I'll be honest didn't care much for the
Netflix show was a little
not bummed but was kind of like I don't
really need Netflix inspired gear and
and in this game because I think their
version of The Witcher is so good that
that would kind of water it down if that
makes sense I know I'm probably thinking
way too much into it but that's kind of
how I felt um but after playing the
quest and getting that gear it adds so
much context to to it and it makes sense
in that world which which I think is
great even if you don't really want to
replay The Witcher 3 for this I highly
recommend loading up a completed game
save maybe checking out this Quest
because there's some there's some cool
surprises
nice I cannot wait to get my hands on
this update also because it's cross
saved so I can just like throw my save
back and forth between my PC and my
PlayStation
um and but when does it come out again
comes out December 14th uh the update is
coming to basically every platform
however uh different platforms are going
to get different
stuff like obviously Ray tracing isn't
going to show up in the switch version
um and I think PC which I didn't get to
test gets some extra fine tuning when it
comes to Graphics which is which is cool
for those who have
you know 40 80s 30 30 80s whatever
yep I think I remember them saying
something about a Ultra Plus setting on
the PC version so that should be fun to
see if my computer can handle it yeah
all right thank you so much
um for speaking to me about about The
Witcher I don't need to play any more of
it because I haven't be in God of War
Ragnarok yet but it's I'm gonna be
playing it on the 14th so let us know in
the comments if you're going to be
jumping back into the Witcher or if it's
going to be your first time and we'll
see you in the next one